millions of families across the nation
are no longer safe from eviction and
housing advocates warn
we could be headed toward a massive wave
of homelessness
moratorium on evictions for federally
backed housing expired last week
it covered more than 12 million
households
but the actual number of people facing
possible evictions
could be much higher adriana diaz spoke
to families in danger of losing their
homes she joins us from chicago good
morning adriana
good morning so renters are now at the
mercy of state laws and just like mask
wearing policies
there's a patchwork of eviction policies
that vary by state
now as we're working on this story one
statistic that really struck us
is that in 17 states black women are
twice as likely as
white renters to be evicted
shamika rollins eight children share two
bedrooms here in richmond virginia
but she's worried about losing their
home after she says she received an
eviction notice
in june first thing i panicked and then
next thing i looked
and i'm like i got my kids and it's like
okay now you got to figure this out
she was behind on rent before the
pandemic grandma is ready
then as kovitt appeared half her income
disappeared when her hours as a home
health aide were
cut her family helped her pay roughly 8
thousand dollars in owed rent but she's
still behind
it's got to be overwhelming i have a lot
of sleepless nights my man is constantly
racing you know what's your next move
catherine azar in colorado works with
show horses but has been out of work
and unable to pay rent since march she
told us she hasn't seen a dollar of
unemployment money
it's a nightmare i don't think anybody
should have to go through this
if she can't get the money together or
work out a deal by today
she'll head to eviction court it's hard
for me
to conceive of
someone being willing to put another
person
out in the street in the middle of a
deadly
pandemic and i'm high risk i'm 70
i have heart issues and i'm diabetic
they're just two of the 43 million
americans at risk of eviction in the
coming months
for context about 1 million americans
were evicted in the year
after the great recession and 30 states
currently allow evictions to continue
during the pandemic as eviction bans
start to phase out across the country
are we
looking at a tsunami of evictions i
don't think that tsunami
can adequately capture the number of
cases that we anticipate
seeing demerica brooks thinks it'll be
worse
she's the director of housing at legal
age chicago
the courts are going to be flooded
unless landlords make a good faith
effort to try to be patient and also to
try to resolve
rent dispute issues in a way that does
not involve the court system
your method to enforce your lease is by
using the courts and filing an eviction
action
landlord paul arena is with the illinois
rental property owners association
he argues the pandemic has actually had
a minimal impact on rent payments so far
members of his organization have sued
illinois's governor
over the state's evictions ban arguing
landlords are unfairly bearing the
burden
what about all the people advocates who
say it's just plain wrong to evict
someone during a pandemic
you know it's always a miserable
experience to vic people somebody who's
experiencing it can show that they have
a
legitimate hardship you know we're
willing to work with them
but to deny us access to the courts
where you can sort everything out
that's a problem studies show women of
color are at higher risk of eviction
this florida mother lost her waitressing
job and her home
during the pandemic she's been living in
a motel
her kids are staying with her mother
like at night
it really hits me like when i can't even
you know tuck my kids into bed it gets
very emotional we interviewed her days
after she tested positive for coving
i feel like i'm getting hit from left to
right with
everything going on with my situation
it's like what's next
two days later she was hospitalized with
symptoms
a health and housing crisis colliding
now i did speak to her on the phone and
she is out of the hospital thankfully
and doing much better
as for shamika rollins her landlord said
that they offer rent relief programs and
always encourage tenants to seek help
through state
programs and for catherine azar her
landlord said that she's tried to work
something out with azar
but so far they haven't been able to
reach an agreement
eureka very very difficult situation
just how this pandemic is affecting
people in so many other ways adriana
thank you